bonjour à toutes et à tous et bonne
semaine bon lundi
notre invité ce matin et jean françois
moreau bonjour bonjour à vous vous êtes
le directeur régional de l'ademe donc l'
agence de l'environnement et de la
maîtrise de l'énergie en martinique et
jean françois moreau la semaine dernière
avec vos partenaires pour la transition
énergétique vos partenaires que sont la
ctm de semaine la dl et edf
vous avez tiré un bilan à kazimi
parcours du ptm eux il faut comprendre
le programme territorial de maîtrise de
l'énergie qui courent de 2016 à 2020
donc voilà on effectivement ça fait
trois ans qu'il a été mise en oeuvre
où en sommes-nous justement jean
françois moreau alors ce pmu il a été
voulu par là la collectivité
territoriale et l'idée c'était vraiment
d'associer les principaux partenaires de
l'énergie sur le territoire à savoir
l'ademe le ce même et edf pour associer
notre expertise et nos moyens financiers
se pétait un peu c'est avant tout un
outil qui aide à faire il est doté sur
la période 2016-2020 de près de 50
millions d'euros auxquels peuvent se
surajouter 40 millions de revenus des
fonds européens feder à la discrétion de
la collectivité territoriale
nos deux principales priorités pour
réussir cette transition énergétique
c'est d'abord les économies d'énergie et
ensuite le développement des énergies
renouvelables pour produire une énergie
qui soit la plus renouvelable possible
le premier bilan que nous pouvons tirer
les premiers indicateurs que nous avons
retenu c'est d'abord du quantitatif sur
ses trois premières années c'est près de
200 projets qui ont été soutenues et
accompagnées par le ptm eux ça
représente une aide d'environ 13
millions d'euros est ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que l'ensemble du
territoire martinique est concernée
parce que la quasi totalité des communes
de l'île ont bénéficié d'un soutien des
pme
et puis dans les faits ce qu'on voit
c'est que la consommation énergétique de
la martinique notamment électrique n'a
de cesse de baisser depuis 2016
quasiment 2% par an avec un une économie
record en 2018 de 33 millions de
kilowattheures c'est l'équivalent d'une
semaine durant laquelle la martinique
aurait arrêté de consommer de
l'électricité
et puis en termes d'énergies
renouvelables longtemps on a eu un tour
de plafond de verre en dessous de 10% de
notre
production d'électricté d'électricité
produite par les énergies renouvelables
bien ce plafond de verre il a été il a
cédé récemment puisque aujourd'hui 25 %
de notre électricité est d'origine
renouvelable
sachant que l'objectif à atteindre il
est quand même extrêmement ambitieux
c'est l'autonomie électrique et
énergétique à 2030
donc ça nous donne un petit peu le le
chemin qui reste à qui reste à parcourir
mais en tout cas le train est lancé on
va dire comme ça alors le train est
lancé et donc vous estimez vous que on
s'est bien engagé dans ce dans cette
transition énergétique et que nous nous
sommes bien bien avancés dans le domaine
en quelque sorte c'est ce que vous venez
de décrire la saa paraît a priori assez
encourageant les premiers signaux sont
encourageants pour autant voilà il faut
être très vigilant
d'abord faire oeuvre de pédagogie parce
qu'aujourd'hui ces questions
énergétiques
elles sont pour grand nombre dans la
population elles sont pas palpables
autant sur le sujet des déchets un vh eu
un véhicule hors d'usagé
une décharge sauvage ça se voit et
facilement on se dire il faut faire
qu'elle va sur un peu plus abstrait
voilà les questions énergétiques elles
sont un petit peu plus abstraite et il
faut faire passer un certain nombre de
messages notamment en termes d'économie
d'énergie sur la climatisation sur
l'isolation l'isolation c'est pas
simplement pour lutter contre le froid
c'est aussi pour se préserver des
apports du soleil notamment donc et puis
pareil dans l'est dans les entreprises
où chaque chaque économie sur les
process à ça à sa valeur donc l'enjeu
c'est de porter toujours ses messages et
de proposer aux acteurs du territoire
que soient les ménages les entreprises
les collectivités un cadre lisible à la
fois sur des aspects réglementaires mais
aussi sur des aspects financiers avec ce
soutien du ptm qui permettent à chacun
de s'engager et de mener à son échelle
des actions c'est l'objectif du ptm
voilà alors vous de vous parliez
justement de de donner davantage
peut-être de d'expression concrète à ce
programme donc de transition énergétique
ce programme territorial de maîtrise de
l'énergie
alors quelques exemples peut-être
le ou les deux exemples les plus
emblématiques des premières réalisations
qui ont été faites justement au cours de
ses trois premières années de ce
programme
si vous autorisez 3 je vais dire ça très
rapidement d'abord chez les ménages
comme moi c'est un regain d'intérêt pour
le chauffe eau solaire et 7 c'est
quelque chose de très performant qui
génère beaucoup d'économies aujourd'hui
on est à un rythme de 8000 nouvelles
installations par an il ya quasiment un
foyer sur quatre qui aujourd'hui est
occupé et conseillers équipe et non pas
par un chauffe eau solaire donc ça c'est
c'est une belle dynamique
et puis on peut on peut citer la marina
du marin il ya eu un reportage récemment
sur votre antenne sur le sujet la marina
du homard un véritable projet de
territoire à la fois énergie et déchets
le recours au solaire thermique eau
solaires photovoltaïques pour alimenter
les bâtiments pour alimenter des
véhicules électriques et puis une
gestion des déchets intelligente sur le
site toujours en photovoltaïque en
autoconsommation on a une vingtaine de
projets qui ont émergé on peut citer par
exemple l'agent ce jumbo car au lamentin
qui loue des véhicules et qui a une
installation photovoltaïque qui lui
permet de couvrir ses consommations
énergétiques du bâtiment mais aussi de
mettre à disposition cette énergie pour
de la recharge de véhicules électriques
et à une première flotte de quatre
véhicules électriques à disposition des
clients
donc voilà autant d'exemples on peut on
pourrait en citer sur des bâtiments
performants on pourrait en citer au
sujet du grand programme de rénovation
de l'éclairage public des communes 200
projets alors donc voilà on va peut-être
vous interroger sur ce qui reste à venir
qu'est-ce qui est le plus prioritaire où
ce qui est déjà engagé mais il est
important de dire à ce stade justement
de notre échange concernant cette
transition que vous-même l'ademe vous
êtes aussi comment dirais-je un
organisme qui délivrait des conseils
personnalisés notamment aux entreprises
puisque vous avez cités là où deux
exemples oui l'ademe celle agence de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie vous l'avez dit c'est une
agence qui existe depuis plus de 20 ans
qui est présente sur l'ensemble des
territoires et notamment les territoires
ultramarins en martinique petite équipe
de 12 personnes mais notre mission c'est
de conseiller les entreprises
collectivités dans cette transition
énergétique les conseillers parce que
c'est pas le coeur de métier des
collectivités de faire des énergies
renouvelables c'est pas toujours pour
nos petites entreprises locales la
possibilité d'avoir en leur sein des
compétences sur ces sujets donc on est
là pour les aider pour les aider avec
cette expertise mais aussi avec nos
financements dans le cadre du ptm eux
mais aussi des financements en propre
qu'on peut mobiliser en soutien de ses
réacteurs
donc là il y reste à peu près un an et
demi on est dans cet ordre là à peu près
16 18 mois donc pour ce programme dans
ce qui reste à venir qu'est-ce qui est
ce qu on peut souligner le toujours ses
actions d'information et de recours aux
économies d'énergie le développement des
énergies renouvelables avec deux grands
sujets le sujet de la géothermie sur le
territoire martiniquais
il ya de vraies potentialités mais ça a
du mal a justement à émerger ça parce
que parce que c'est
c'est un sujet complexe avec une part de
risque que les opérateurs
on peut peut-être du mal à assumer à ce
stade mais l'objectif du ptm eux c'est
de mener toutes les études préalables
pour minimiser ce risque et faire qu'un
acteur privé avec le soutien de la
collectivité puisse investir et
développer ses projets de géothermie
soir au lamentin soit aux anses d'arlet
ya le sujet de la petite
hydroélectricité parce qu'on ne peut
faire l'économie d'aucun potentiel on a
des cours d'eau certains qui présente
des intérêts pour développer de petites
centrales de production électrique
et puis enfin le transport et la
mobilité parce que c'est peut-être là
que les choses sont les plus tarder le
plus à à se décanter notamment en termes
de d'état d'esprit on peut difficilement
imaginer continuer à circuler seul dans
sa voiture en heure de pointe
donc voilà changer un petit peu les
comportements faire émerger de nouveaux
services des transports en commun
martinique transport y y travaillent
et puis accompagné pour le pt m e la
mobilité électrique
le développement du véhicule électrique
concomitamment au fait que notre
électricité soit une électricité
d'origine renouvelable
développé à tout bout de champ
l'électromobilité aujourd'hui alors que
il ya quand même une grande partie de
notre électricité qui est encore
d'origine fossile
ça serait une hérésie donc on essaye de
le faire de manière raisonnée alors
précisément on en vient justement à
cette autonomie énergétique que vous
pensez possible vous à l'ademe agence de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie dont vous êtes le directeur
régional jean françois moreau ou penser
qu'il est possible pour la martinique
d'atteindre l'autonomie énergétique en
vous avez même mené une étude a ici qui
vise essentiellement à justement à lever
les freins techniques au développement
des énergies renouvelables qui
permettrait cette autonomie énergétique
alors pour que les gens comprennent bien
c'est à dire qu'on on aurait quasiment
plus besoin d'importer de de pétrole
enfin deux voilà de carburant pour
fonctionner ici en martinique exactement
l'ademe un travail de loges de
prospective mettant en valeur notre
expertise que d'une vingtaine d'années
que j'ai que j'évoquais donc on a lancé
un grand chantier qui est évoqué à qui
visait à évaluer la possibilité d'une
autonomie énergétique sur les
territoires insulaires et notamment en
martinique ce fameux mix électrique 100%
énergies renouvelables que vous indiquez
tout à l'heure c'est à dire solaire
géothermie éolien enfin ce qu'on peut se
dire les conclusions de cette étude
c'est que cette autonomie énergétique
elle est possible mais à deux conditions
d'abord de réduire de manière
significative nos consommations
d'énergie et donc devrait dans tous les
secteurs d'activité et ensuite de ne
négliger aucun potentiel d'énergies
renouvelables c'est pour ça que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
l'hydroélectricité c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'imaginait pas possible en
martinique on pourra pas faire
l'économie de c2c de ces sources
renouvelables
sachant que le socle c'est ce que vous
avez évoqué c'est le solaire à la fois
thermique et photovoltaïque c'est la
géothermie
c'est l'éolien on l'a vu au travers du
parc grand rivière qui a été livré en
fin d'année l'éolien en martinique
c'est possible et au travers
l'intervention du ptm il ya à priori
d'autres porteurs de projets qui se
manifeste et on pourrait voir de
nouvelles installations éoliennes
émerger pour contribuer à cet automne
alors justement on va on va conclure
vous parlez de porter de porteurs de
projets pour conclure il faut rappeler
qu'il y a un programme dead
aux économies d'énergie pour la
martinique copiloté avec les partenaires
que nous avons déjà cité par par l'ademe
alors un programme de 97 millions doté
de 97 millions pour pour la martinique
dites nous en quelques mots pour oui
c'est assez confus c'est le cadre de
compensation de maîtrise de l'énergie
c'est comment on facilite les économies
d'énergie auprès des entreprises et
aider et des ménages pour en dire
quelques mots en fait c'est un pari sur
l'avenir
aujourd'hui le coût de l'électricité ou
qu'on soit est le même malheureusement
produire de l'électricité en martinique
ça coûte plus cher que de le produire en
région paca et donc ça coûte à l'état
français de maintenir cette péréquation
est plutôt que de maintenir cette
péréquation
l'enjeu c'est de mobiliser cet argent
pour faire que les gens fassent des
économies d'énergie facilité facilite le
recours aux économies d'énergie pour que
la consommation plus tard soit moins
importante de ses 97 millions c'est
destiné à la fois aux entreprises et aux
particuliers aux métiers complémentaires
aux aides du ptm et c'est à la fois les
entreprises et les ménages
prenons le cas d'un dut du solaire
thermique vous voulez installer un
chauffe eau solaire chez vous vous
pouvez bénéficier d'une aide de la
collectivité territoriale et d'edf
situé en fonction de vos revenus entre
1000 et 1350 euros
un brasseur d'air de la même façon vous
avez un soutien pour les ménages 1 de
l'électroménager performant vous avez
également une prime souvent ça fait
affichage dans dans la ville donc ce
sont des dispositifs qui aujourd'hui
existe qui mérite d'être connu et donc
j'invite chacun à aller mobiliser très
bien merci jean françois moureau donc on
retiendra en conclusion que nous sommes
bien engagés mais faut donner encore
deux trois coups de collier changera
cassé un os de rim est effectivement la
route est encore longue et et la pente
ardue mais pour autant on est sur le
chemin
merci jean françois moreau directeur
régional de l'ademe d'avoir été dans sa
ou qu'a dit ce matin bonne journée à
vous tous merci à vous